But in the same way our visions inspireus,
they can also start to limit us.
If we hear the same narratives
over and overagain,
and if we see the same
visuals over and over again,
then that becomes our scope of possibility.
That becomes our benchmark for
what we believe is good and what's not.
Talk to your grandmother asked
her how she imagines the future,
and I bet youshe'll tell you that
no one asks her that anymore
or read that Filipino science fiction novel,
watch a Nigerian, post apocalyptic film.
Look for stories that ask what
if from a newperspective,
when we choose to be curious
about the alternatives and
when we take them seriously,
we'll start to think in new ways,
will solve problems in new ways,
and we'll just start tosee possibilities
that we couldn't see before.